what's your gut what's your hope as a
scientist as a human how many alien
civilizations are out there
as a ex-physicist i'm now much more on
the aerospace engineering side for space
architecture but as an ex-physicist i
hope it is
uh prolific
i think the challenge is if it's as
prolific as we would hope if there are
many many many civilizations then the
question is
where are they why haven't we heard from
them and the fermi paradox is there some
great filter that life only gets to some
level of sophistication and then kills
itself off through war or through famine
or through different challenges that
filter that
society out of existence and it would be
an interesting question to try to
understand if the universe was teeming
with life why haven't we
found it or heard from it yet to our
knowledge yeah i mean i personally
believe that it's teeming with life and
you're right i think that's a really
useful productive engineering scientific
question
of what kind of great filter yeah can
just be destroying all that life or
preventing it from
just constantly talking to to us silly
the
of apes that's a really nice question
like
what are the ways civilizations can
destroy themselves
and there's too many sadly well we i
don't think we've come up with most of
them yet that's also probably true
that's the thing it's uh
i mean and like if you look at nuclear
war some of it is physics
but some of it is game theory it's uh
it's human nature it's how society's
built themselves how they interact
how we create and resolve conflict and
it gets back to the human question on
when you're doing long-term space travel
how do you
maintain this dynamical system of
of flawed
uh irrational humans such that it
persists
throughout time to not just maintain
their biological body but get people
from not murdering each other and like
like each other sufficiently to where
you kind of fit well but i think you
know if uh the songs or poetry or books
taught me anything if you like each
other a little too much
um
i mean the problems arise because then
there's always a third person who also
likes and then there's the drama he's
like i can't believe you did that and
then last night whatever so and then
there's beer
you